alright guys so before I go on to teach
are multiple edges at a time I'd like to
just briefly review how the beginners
method works what we're doing in the
beginners method is we're only pairing
up two edge pieces here we have two
blue-white edge pieces so we would pair
it up and then we would replace it with
an unmatched pair so that we can twist
the center's back and not break up that
newly matched pair so now we have one
newly matched pair and that's the way
the beginners method works you do that
step-by-step however for the advanced
method what we're going to be doing is
we're going to be able to instead of
turning the center's back every time
we're going to be able to set it up so
that when we turn them to twist it out
of alignment we're going to be making
three edge pairs and then when we twist
it back we're going to be making another
three so that's a total of six edge
pairs completed with just one slice of
the cube all right so what we want to do
is basically we want to first of all we
want to set it up I'm going to show you
how exactly it's going to work with just
two pairs and then I'll go on to show
you six so we already have this one here
so if we look at the piece down here the
pieces in the bottom two layers are not
going to be turned when you're matching
up the pieces because we're twisting the
top faces towards the bottom faces so
you could see that these pieces are
remaining stationary so what that means
is that if I twist this out of alignment
and then I replace this newly matched
pair with a pair that has the other blue
red piece here that means when I twist
the center's back it will also form a
blue red pair so let me show you exactly
how you would go about doing that so
before you match it up you have to find
that blue red pair the blue red piece if
we look around the cube the other blue
red piece is down here so what you would
do is you want to get it in the top
layer if you can
so now it's over here so now we would do
is we would match it up and now we want
the top piece here to be this blue piece
the blue red edge piece so what we would
do is we would basically lift it up out
of the way bring this around and then
put that down so that when we bring the
center's back now will also form a blue
red pair so let me do that again real
quick so here we have the blue white and
the blue white we have the other piece
here so when we twist it and match that
we could bring this piece around another
way that you can replace it instead of
lifting this up and then switching it
out what you could do is you could bring
it here and then you want this piece you
want this piece to be here but you see
you can't just put it like that and
twist it back because these centers have
to be horizontal so what you need to do
is you bring this down here and kick it
out since this is now horizontal we want
to keep it like that but we want to fix
this one so once you kick it out watch
the centers you kick it out and you
bring it down then you fix these centers
and then you would fix these centers and
then you'll see that preserves the
orientation of these two pieces and then
we could switch it back and then we form
that okay so to do more advanced edge
pairing you're going to need to create
what's called a build ring in which you
place edge pieces around the cube so
that when you twist it you get a few
edge pairs and then when you twist it
back you're going to be replacing it
with pieces so that they also create
edge pairs and now I'm going to show you
how to do that
alright guys so in order to match up six
edge pairs at a time what we need to do
is to create the build ring so you might
be asking what the building is the build
ring is basically edge pieces which
we're going to align in the middle two
layers here all the way around the cube
we're going to be matching three edge
pairs so when we slice the center's
we're going to have three newly matched
edge pairs instead of just one or two as
in the beginner method so right now we
have one I have a green white piece and
I have another green white piece here
when we twist the top two centers to
match these green white pieces you'll
see that this piece here is going to
also go to the right so this one will
match up with this one and this piece
the blue yellow piece is going to come
over here so if we can get the other
blue yellow piece to be here when we
twist it we're going to make another
newly matched pair so that's how we
basically create the build ring we just
line them up three in a row basically so
we have one where's the other yellow
blue piece now so we look around the
cube and the other yellow blue piece is
over here so if we basically just turn
this all the way around it will be
aligned you're not going to be able to
match them up like that all the way
around the cube because it's going to
eventually interfere with the first one
so we have one edge pair here we have
another here and we could do one more so
it is the purple white piece where is
the other purple white piece it's right
here so we basically just need to align
it so if this piece needs to go over
here what we can do is we can twist it
down bring it up and then twist it back
and as you'll see these pieces are now
in the build ring so we have one edge
pair ready to be aligned two and three
so now what we do is we go to the first
one and we bring it over we basically
just slice the center's like we would to
match up the edge pairs when we do that
you'll see we have one two and three
there is basically only one edge pair
open here that is not going to be
matched okay so now what we need to do
is once we have them aligned and matched
we want to get them out of the way so we
can keep them the way they are we don't
want to lose these pieces which we just
aligned so we're going to be bringing
the center's back this way we're going
to be bringing blue back to blue yellow
back to yellow and so forth so as you'll
see this piece is going to go here when
we do that so if we can get the other
yellow red piece to be here on the
bottom that means that this will match
up with that piece so if we could find
that piece which is right here so
because this is on the top here it's in
the upper inside layer we want this
piece to be in the inner down layer so
we needed to be here so as you'll see it
is in the inner down layer here so if we
can get it to be here that will that
will be fine it will be in the build
ring so we bring it here and then we
bring this piece up now you'll see
they're opposite but they're not in the
building the building is going in this
direction so we have to fix the center's
like twisting it down and now these
pieces are in the building and as you'll
see that newly matched pair is in the
top layer so now this is going to be
brought this way so we have one and then
we have the blue white piece well
where's the other blue white piece the
other blue white piece is here so to get
it in the build ring we need it in the
lair here so what we can do is we
basically do the same thing we bring it
here we can bring this up and then we
realign the center so that these pieces
are now in the building then we have one
more so it is the green yellow piece
where is the other green yellow piece
the other green yellow piece is already
in the build ring as you'll see but it's
on the opposite side so what we do is we
basically just kick this piece out and
replace it with any unmatched pair and
now you'll see when we bring these
centers back these two pieces will be
aligned and you basically haven't lost
anything by doing that you'll have a
piece ready now to be matched up and as
you'll see we should now have six edge
pairs which have been matched so I hope
that helped you out and getting a little
bit quicker at the 4x4 cube it's
slightly different for the 5x5 cube but
you should be able to pick it up with
that as well